في احتفالات السنه الجديده هناك بعض
المحرمات التي لا يفضل القيام بها اولا لا
يسمح بالكنز او التخلص من القمامه قبل
اليوم الخامس لان ذلك يرمز للتخلص من الحظ
السعيد الكلمات ذات الدلالات السلبيه
ممنوعه خلال الاحتفالات وتشمل الموت
والمرض والفقر والالم والفراغ والقتل
والسبب منع النحس او جلب هذه المفردات
لاقاربك كسر الزجاج او السيراميك ممنوع
ايضا لانها تعني قطع الاتصال بالازدهار
والثروه لكن اذا سقط طبق وانكسر عن طريق
الخطا فيمكن لفه في ورق ورميه في بحيره
صالونات تصفيف الشعر مغلقه خلال الاعياد
وهو من المحرمات اذ ان المقص يقطع الخيط
الواصل بالنجاح والثروه في اوقات الاعياد
يرتاح المديون اذ انه من غير المحبه
المطالبه بسداد الاموال لانها ستجلب الحظ
السيء للدائن يفضل تجنب البكاء وتناول
الادويه لمنع الاصابه بالمرض طوال العام
الا اذا كانت مساله حياه او موت